foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar clinical
utility of digital PCR in liquid biopsy
for the management of cancer
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
atosha Romero head of the liquid biopsy
laboratory at hospital
universitario Puerto yero Madrid Spain
atosha you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you Thermo feature specific for
inviting us to present our work I am
Atocha Romero I am the liquid biopsy
laboratory at hospital
I work at the medical oncology
department and I'm going to be talking
about the clinical utility of liquid
biopsy for the management of cancer
patients more specifically for the
management of lung cancer patients
okay so by liquid biopsy we refer to
several approaches we can conduct to
obtain molecular information for the
team from the tumors in an uninvasive
way there are many components in the
blood that we can analyze such as ctcs
EVS or extracellular vesicles
proteins RNA circulating tumor DNA I'm
going to be focusing
um I'm going to be focused mostly in the
analysis of circulating tumor DNA
so there is circulating free DNA in the
bloodstream because uh diets dying cells
shed DNA into the bloodstream and in
cancer patients a small proportion of
this circulating free DNA is actually
circulating tumor DNA
so the analysis of circulating tumor DNA
has been shown to be useful for
non-invasive biomarker testing this is
especially important in some cancer
patients such as for example lung cancer
patients patients in home it is
sometimes difficult in a biopsy with
sufficient material for biomarker
testing
um because ctdna levels has been shown
uh to correlate well with tumor bulk and
it's a city DNA quantification it is
also useful to monitor uh cancer disease
um also using very sensitive techniques
uh we can use City DNA or liquid body
for a minimal receivable disease
monitoring of course we can genotype uh
or we can do molecular profiling over
the course of treatment of disease and
this can give us information about the
clonal revolution of the tumors and also
there is now an intense research in
evaluating the utility of City DNA in in
the screening programs and I guess that
probably in the future radionics
combining radionics with liquid biopsy
for the yield very uh
I think good results and may may
facilitate the incorporation of
screening effective screening programs
which may may have an impact on on
Survival especially in some cancers such
as lung cancer
the amount of CT DNA depends on tumor
type size stage and metastasis
there are some some tissues such as for
example brain or bone
Thirty little DNA into the bloodstream
and of course size stage of metastasis
the amount of ctdna depends on size
States and metastases and that is why
ctdna has been shown to be of a
prognostic significance
so regarding technical issue we of
course uh the most uh used sample is
blood but there is circulating tumor DNA
in other liquids such as for example
urine and in this
um
paper we published a couple of years ago
we showed that City DNA from body fluids
is another great source for biomarker
testing this was performed on lung
cancer patients with an idea of
permutations and here what we saw it is
that the amount of circulating tumor DNA
in malignant effusions that occurred as
a consequence of disease progression
DNA in this sample is very high and
therefore these samples are very
informative and should not be discarded
uh for biomarker testing in some cases
because
they may be really helpful in some
situations
I'm more sophisticated uh we saw in in
this paper we show it that peritoneal
Washings which are root enable uh
performed in ovarian cancer patients
these pregnenol Watsons are uh another
great store for for somatic bracha
testing
and so in this paper we saw a very high
concordance between fpp sample and the
better Theory wasn't samples uh this uh
might be useful this this starting
material might be useful when the fpp
samples are not sufficient or the
quality of of the sample not enough or
for NGS procedure for whatever reason
uh of course uh if we want to analyze
circulating tumor DNA we need uh
techniques with a very low limit of
detection uh uh below
0.1 percent or lower
um so um several Technologies such as
NDS plans or data this year have been
shown to be
adequate for this this kind of analysis
here I'm sewing
um a correlation between two different
PCR platforms absolute q and Quantum
studio and you can see a perfect
correlation between both Technologies
this is also a null paper from our lab
in which we tested or the agreement
between NDS and City DNA and digital PCR
sorry for City DNA genotyping and wish I
had a very high agreement
and in the same way this is a bigger
study
in which we evaluated the agreement
between seven methodologies for
non-invasive biomarket testing
specifically we evaluated two different
and NGS platform uh three detail
platforms and to FDA platforms and
overall we saw with that detailed
platforms and India platform had higher
sensitivity than FDA approved platforms
and that most discordant calls occurred
when the mutation was edited at a very
low allele frequencies so it is very
important to assess the quality of
variant goals because in liquid biopsy
and in some cases with in most cases the
imitations are detected at very low
allele frequencies in order to assess
the variant of the the is to assess the
quality sorry of a variant called we
develop of this score which we name it
RS code and this score takes inflacode
to parameters one is is the mapd which
refers to the uniformity in coverage in
a given result and the other is the
allele frequency so combining these two
parameters into this formula we can
calculate the r score and here in this
paper we saw that the concordance
between two different NGS Platforms in
assessing in invariant code was
and very poor uh when our score was very
high on the contrary with a very low R
score the core the agreement between
NGS Platforms in variant called
was uh almost perfect
here you can
nicely see that there is a a very high
correlation between the agreement
in assessing a variant called and the
rscore
so
as I mentioned cddna profiling has been
shown to be an adequate method to inform
clinical decisions making especially in
a small thing lung cancer as ctdna NGS
profiling has been shown to be highly
concordant with tissue and DS profiling
what is more important is that adding
plasma cdvna sequence into tissue
genotyping in the clinical setting
putting please the detection of
stereotable mutations and therefore will
expand the possibility for a targeter a
targeted therapy in a given patient
um
in any case if we don't find any
mutation in the plasma of a given
patient we should
try as much as we can to genotype the
tumor tissue to confirm and detect
results in the plasma sample
one of the most important approaches of
liquid biopsy is a molecular profiling
upon disease progression so once a
patients have been diagnosed as having
progression Progressive disease
it is very difficult to obtain for
example in lung cancer patients at
isobiopsy because in most cases the
patient is unwilling or
the healthy conditions
are not other ways to undergo an an
invasive procedure
so
um a few years ago when Ulster madini
which is a
tyrosyncinase inhibitor was
used as a second line treatment in efr
positive not a small Finland camper
patients after the patient had was
diagnosed as having a progressive
disease the liquid biopsy and digital
PCR were very useful to identified
patients who could benefit from this
drug because the tumors had to have to
be positive for the t7idm resistance
mutation and it is very easy and it
rather cheap to test a single mutation
by digital this year of course this
scenario is now a little bit obsolete
because obviously maintenance is used
mostly as a first line treatment and not
as a second length but
it is still and in some scenarios could
be useful too I analyze a single
mutation by digital piece here in this
paper we have published last year we
um and we demonstrated that the
prevalence of the g12c mutation in Keras
was one percent in efr positive uh not a
small cell lung cancer patients after
progressing on a first line treatment
with a tyrosynchinace inhibitor so it is
well established the well-established
that gave transmutations and efr
mutations are mutually exclusive but
it's also well established that gave us
mutations may appear as a consequence of
resistance of as a mechanism of
resistance to a tyrosync and ACE
inhibitors and specifically by in this
paper we genotype it by using in the
digital this year 500 samples and we
could a
estimate that the prevalence of this
draggable mutation is one percent in
these patients upon this is a
progression
and
sorry a similar scenario is in all
positive tumors so how positive and
translocations in in ALK
occur in about five percent of the
locals
and these patients can benefit from
um from several I target targeted
Therapies
um unfortunately a base tumors progress
and due to the development of resistance
mechanisms and resistance mutations many
several resistance mutations have been
described in the out Locus
the important thing here is that that a
given mutation May confer resistance to
a given drug but not to all of them and
knowing the molecular status at this is
progression would would help to better
prescribe second line and third line
treatment in these patients because they
in this way they oncologist will now if
the drug if the drug is effective in a
in a given tumor
uh so
in this way we perform a starting with
24
non-small 3 lung cancer patients with an
all translocation were include they were
all metastatic and a sample uh blood
sample was collected upon disease
progressions in our hands about one
third of the patients or more than one
third of the patients had um
resistance mutation in the unlocos and
these are the mutations that we we
detected and which is concordance with
the what it has been published so again
and this article saw that at least for
this for this subset of patients and
knowing the molecular status or the
molecular molecular profile upon this is
progression would help to optimize a
second and third line treatment
analyzing fusions
such as translocations is more
challenging
in in the solid tumors alph fusions are
identified by peace
immunostochemistry or NGS
in the liquid biopsy we can identify if
efficient by city in the city DNA by
genotyping the city DNA but this boot
required to use a large panel and a a
very high and read the the panel at a
very high coverage
um we can also another approach is to
sequence the fusion transcript at the at
the RNA level however the RNA in the
blood degrades very easily and therefore
one approach would be to
um analyze the RNA inside the exosomes
or platelets which is uh protected from
the aeronases in the blood
so we
um
in in in a study we perform we wanted to
to know whether this Arc Fusion
transcripts are present in extrateral
vesicles from all positive known as
multiple lung cancer patients and also
we tested this was also true in 10 lines
Harbor in this alteration
so in our hands we could demonstrate
that the fusion transcript at the mrla
level another protein level is present
in the extracellular vesicles from uh
the third lines and also from the from
the patients and this was demonstrated
for the first time as far as we know and
um importantly we characterize very well
this vesicle according to Mrs guidelines
so we characterize the vesicles by
electron microscopy NTA EXO View and
more importantly we could demonstrate
that the fusion transcript the outfusion
was present in exosomes in in vesicles
institutional vesicles from the cell
lines and also in extracurricular
vesicles from the tumor so the blue dots
corresponds to the alt piercings
and this was also demonstrated at the
protein level so here I'm so in the
western blood uh where the
vesicles from the from the
um
cell lines Harbor in this alteration so
that there is diffusion at the protein
level and not in the melanoma cell which
is not
do not Harbor these alterations and in
the right uh in the left side is the the
worst of rock from lysates and that of
course you can see again that the
infusion protein is present in the cell
lines
and this was also demonstrated in a
different experiment in about blood
so this is very important because this
opens the door for a non-invasive
biomarket test team based on TVs and I
think now the challenge is on developing
methods for obtaining a ebis containing
this information in a more efficient way
or in a in a very efficient way that can
be
can be incorporated in the clinical in
in Daily oncology in the clinical
setting
so regarding more retaining as I
mentioned the amount of circulating
tumor DNA correlates well with with
tumor bulk this is an old paper from our
lab in which
um a cohort of egfr positive on a small
trend line cancer patients were
monitored by City DNA and using digital
this year and here you can see in the
left figure in the left panel that the
the corresponds to
monitor the ctdna levels in a in a
patient with an efra positive known as
Monster
so as you can see at Baseline the city
DNA's levels were very high and the
Orange Line corresponds to the original
efrosensitizing notation and this
corresponds with the image label with
the star a in which you could see very
clearly that there was an uptake in the
CTS scan in the lungs and liver and in
many places and this patient did very
well as you can see and with no
detectable mutations a few after the
start of the treatment we started using
NS inhibitor and corresponding with the
inmates and they will with the VSR
however after a while the patient was
diagnosed as having a heavy disease
progression and also it was seen an
increase but very slightly slight
increase in circulating tumor DNA level
in the plasma sample however this
patient had
um
pericardial efficient due to malignant
pericardial effusion and in this case
the presence of the resistant mutation
the t7id resistant rotation could be
clearly detected by digital piece here
analyzing the pericardial
fluid so again malignant effusions
consequence of disease progressions are
where we
informative in some cases and in this
case as you can see in the blue line and
the the t7i imitation was hardly
detected in the plasma sample
so many authors has proposed that ctvna
could be incorporated in the DNM systems
with help uh helps oncologists to assess
the prognostic of a given patient
because the amount of City DNA as I
mentioned before is of prognostic
significance
we have also see this in in several
studies here I'm presenting a study
conducted by the Spanish lung cancer
group in which a 80 28 Hospital
participated in this study
228 efr positive known as multiple lung
cancer patients will include an 830
liquid biopsies were analyzed samples
were connected were collected sorry
before the start of the treatment at
three six months and a disease
progression and as you can see
circulating two more DNA levels at
baselines and before treatment where of
prognostic significance so in the Kaplan
major Corp that is presented in the
right side and you can see that the
patients with low City DNA level
represented by the green line had
significantly improved overall survival
compared with patients with high
circulating tumor DNA levels a baseline
represented by the yellow line
in addition
City DNA was useful to monitor treatment
so in this couple of major curves you
can see you can focus maybe on the uh
couple may of course for over survival
which is the one on the right side the
one on the left side is for progression
free survival so in this couple of major
Corp the yellow line represents those
patients that did not respond to therapy
so these were patients that in which CD
DNA was still detectable after three or
six months of treatment
Green Line represents to page represents
patients that had
that became City DNA negative after
three or six months of treatment but
patients who had very high levels of
ctdna at baselines and the yellow line
you can see that have a clear uh better
overall survival corresponds to those
patients and that had very low levels of
circulating tumor DNA at Baseline and
these patients all of them had
became CD DNA negative after three or
six months of treatments so clearly
ctdna is a prognostic factor and that
can be used to stratify the risk of
progression of them and death in in
cancer patients and in lung cancer
patients this is another example in in
the same way in another context this is
a clinical trial in which the efficacy
of in order being was evaluated but
again in this context completely
different from the other the previous
one CD DNA was of prognostic
significance
and finally I'm going to be focusing on
the role of City DNA in the new adjuvant
setting so the new and for this I'm
going to be focused or based on the
data reported in the Nadine clinical
trial so the new argument treatment is
the treatment that is given to a patient
before surgery and in this Nadine
clinical trial 46 another small Finland
cancer patients that were diagnosed as
having a 3A disease and whose tumors
were considered to be receptable by a
multidisciplinary team so these patients
were treated with neoagulant plus
chemotherapy and subsequently the
patients underwent surgery and then they
were treated for one year with Agilent
therapy it has to be said that the
program that the statistics for this
subset of patients before the Nadine
trial was that more or less that
um only one third of the patients about
30 percent of the patient were alive
after a three years
from treatment and in Nadine trial this
probability raises over 80 percent in
this trial all the trial and points were
met and this progression free survival
which was the first uh the first trial
end point was 77.1 percent the primary
impulse sorry
uh these results were further uh
confirmed by another important trial
which is the Checkmate a16 this is a
phase 3 trial uh randomized trial and
confirmed their results of Nadine trial
and therefore subsequently this
scheme was approved by
fdas on March this year
so there is now great interest to
explore
um
different combinations in the new
adjuven setting and in this scenario we
need a survival surrogates that that can
be measured faster than overall survival
and progression pre survival in order to
accelerate uh the the the approval of
some drugs or the approval of some
combination or in in in in essence to
accelerate research
and so it has been shown uh very clearly
by Nadine investigator and also by
techmate investigators that pathological
response
is a good surrogate for overall survival
and progression free survival and so in
both trials a pathological complete
response that is having no no to no
tumor cells in the primary tumor when
the the tumor is removed after surgery
or nor in the lymph nodes having no no
malignancy lymph nodes a significantly
correlates with uh survival and also the
Nadine too which the Kaplan major school
for Nadine's two are presented building
in the lower part
confirm this this data the question is
can't a circulating tumor DNA help also
in this in this
of this year and contains the analysis
of people late in tumor DNA in Nadine
clinical samples among other results
and here we saw it that another
patients who had undetectable
circulating tumor DNA after neoadulant
treatment have significantly improved a
progression free survival and overall
survival indicated that this is a good
surrogate for survivals on the contrary
clinical response as assistant
did not predict as a survival outcomes
on this trial CD DNA was analyzed by the
using the oncoming and circulating three
DNA essays and here in this a couple of
Mayor course well I'm presenting Sarah
Kappa Mayer groups uh it has to be said
that in the Nadine trial Baseline that
is spread treatment circulating two more
DNA levels were also a prognostic
significance this is the Kaplan mayor of
in the upper left corner so in Blue Line
represents patients with low CD DNA
levels at baselines and the yellow land
represents patients with high CD DNA 11
at waistline and you can see that
patients with low CD DNA levels at the
line had significantly improved outcome
regarding what happens after new adju1
treatment you can see in the upper right
Kaplan major course that all patients
with apathological complete response
none of the patients with a pathological
complete response
had disease that is that all places
since they that had a pathological
complete response are alive or were
alive at the time of data cutoff and
similarly patients who became CD DNA
negative after neoadulant treatment had
significantly improved overall survival
so patients with analytic table level
of CD DNA have the treatments are
represented by the Blue Line in this
coupler major group on the contrary as I
mentioned the clinical response assessed
on CTF stands did not predict as well as
survival and you can see that the couple
mayor curves which is in the lower part
on the left side
do not separate as nicely as in the
other cases
so finally some limited my major or one
of the most important limitations of the
liquid of cdna genotyping is clonal
hematopoiesis a somatic mutations uh
other mutations
derivative
sorry so this uh these mutations
in blood
this comes from the blood cells or bone
marrow but without the diagnosis of any
metalloical malignancy and these
mutations are more frequent in base in
age patients and in patients with solid
tumors and of course are more uh likely
to be detected with deeper sequencing
approaches and is the most important
source for false positive goals
um
this many Studies have shown that the uh
the the prevalence of chronomatopoieties
derivative mutations uh increases with
age and in some solid tumors such as not
a small salencantha which are diagnosed
in more elderly people but the
prevalence of somatic mutations is uh
rather high so
um therefore
developing pipelines to filter out these
mutations as well as the urine mutations
is really important in in
the liquid biopsy
fields and that is all I wanted to share
with you thank you very much for your
attention and I'd like to thank
um
the Spanish Lancaster group and all the
collaborators I'm not very happy to
respond any anything from the audience
thank you very much
thank you atosha for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
now let's get started
our first question is does CF DNA
extraction method have an impact on CF
DNA analysis
um so
um in a study we have conducted a some
years ago we demonstrated that the
vinylizer profile uh of cpdna could be
different according to the instruction
method although we could not demonstrate
an impact on cdna genotyping this
difference in the populations of where
we cover had an impact on biomarker
testing uh it has been documented by
many researchers the articulating free
DNA recovery
um it can can be different depending on
the instruction method and I think that
reproducibility and robustness in this
par analytical phase is going to be
crucial in order to incorporate City DNA
quantification uh for City for clinical
decision making
great thank you for that
um a next question is do existing
cell-free DNA methods achieve the
sensitivity needed for detecting minimal
residual disease mrd
so now there is a lot of interest in in
liquid biopsy based method for for
detecting a metering minimal residual
disease uh it appears that combining
methylation and genomic signals can
improve sensitivity and probably
combining this information with imagine
information maybe with
radionics I think that would be a good
approach for for measuring this minimal
refuse and disease as well as for maybe
screening programs
great
um another question is what is the
percentage of false positive
[Music]
so uh in the rain trials I I guess this
question is related to the uh Rin trial
that that was presented
in my presentation in a slide in heaven
and so for the rintraya we published
that the sensitivity of different
techniques it was the specificity of uh
NGS and digital piece here was 100
percent
specificity for Exon 21 and Exon 19
deletion detection in efr in and this
sensitivity specificity was a little bit
lower for the detection of the t7 IDM
resistance rotation but it was also
fairly high and this is because the the
this resistance rotation is always
detected at a lower early frequencies
because it appears
in a later stage over in the disease
and yeah I if I I hope I have answered
your questions every in in the green
trial in which we we evaluated the
sensitivity and specificity of different
techniques that was the specificity that
was reported 100
for x121 in of efr and 100 for excellent
19 and a little bit lower for G7 IBM
ever system rotation in efr
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question
um do you think CT DNA will replace
pathological response or clinical
response
no I don't think a CD DNA will replace
the any of them but I think it will help
and will improve the way we measure the
tumor respond to treatment and maybe
incorporating uh City DNA clearance and
will help oncologists to better estimate
tumor responsive treatment together with
the pathological information
great thank you again natosha for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots in our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts and before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those that will be submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with any one of your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
but